kendrick perkins has a multi-million  dollar frenchie business yes this guy it  all started when his brother-in-law  acquired a male and female frenchie and  they bred six puppies the puppy sold in  three days he ended up making 60 grand  from six frenchy his brother-in-law  acquired another female and bred seven  more puppies they all sold out right  away and then at that point perkins was  like okay this works i'm all in they  started their company called bigly  exotics and they currently have 42 dogs  soon perkins learned more and more about  dna he learned that certain dogs with  longer hair and different color can sell  for more he was able to sell a pink  husky frenchie for 250 000  if you're not looking to buy a 250k  frenchie you can also go to a shelter  and adopt one for a very small price  just throwing it out there